all right I reckon it's gonna work
so basically
I had the great idea
of setting up a Nas in the office what
are the odds of CPU died
anyway long story short we can actually
the display like nothing works if I
bought a mask we probably have a net so
let's be honest
[Music]
we did it boys how long has it been
many months okay 26th of July 26th of
July 2022
is when
I opened the claim so 26th of July so
this has been back at the manufacturer
or whatever
for like a month and a half but we
finally did it we finally got a CPU so
basically my process of trying to buy an
AMD CPU has taken about four months
partially due to my kind of uh lack of
haste to resolve the issue because I
just didn't just couldn't be bothered
however what we do have here is a brand
new AMD ryzen 5 5600 G CPU and this is
going into our Nas which we will
hopefully have running
like today unless this one is also
broken in which case rip meet the nurse
this poor fella has been CPU less
for way too long but today we fix that
hey Tim I feel like being a bit of a
cameraman
This Is The Moment of Truth
Verizon
the beautiful cooler stock coolers for
the nas
I think that's reasonable
wow
would your liquid pull an ass probably
not
we are in Australia that's true those
beautiful pins
all fully intact before
channel installation will it remain like
that will it remain like that after
China selection well I guess time will
tell because
as much as I'd like to say yes
who knows like riding a bike am I right
line up this guy
she's in all right got that nice thermal
paste already applied I don't know where
on Earth
this is gonna go like as in the screws
have nowhere to go at the moment and
what is even this whole situation here
this is so dusty
imagine a world without dust is it isn't
is this supposed to be like a back plate
did we take apart the back plant no
remember there's been so many months
oh no I found it
here it is
I found the back plate
it's this little contraption
so this goes on the underside
I guess well actually we could just
install it well I guess I'll install it
first
a bit
stupid of me not to
stab the motherboard all right beautiful
Rock Solid now
we transplant it back into the body now
the motherboard screws I have this
assortment of screws here that has been
sitting here for months
are these the motherboard screws no wait
what are motherboard screws usually look
like Tim you should donate your computer
for research
and we'll see what they look like
whatever they're going in if this CPU
fails on us again then
we'll know what the real problem is yeah
next level um chill Vlog it's just a
real-time office life I mean you did a
live stream of it yeah that's true but
that was different what exactly one yeah
I think it was pretty good people liked
it but you know it's holding through
that again yeah yeah that's all they get
started a new series like every month
and then it's just exactly one episode
even if people really like it it's like
sorry guys it's just on to the next one
on to the next one because you never
know how much you'll like the next one
maybe the next one will be better now
this looks like an empty space Oh the
power supply
wait what else do we realistically need
for this probably nothing
when why is this disconnected
oh that was here wasn't it
well whatever we can attach that later I
want to boot this guy up first and see
see if it works yeah because I've been
hurt before just untangle this fan
and in fact let me just disconnect this
we don't need any Cooling
back at this all week
the CPU Cooler is installed oh no what
about the the M2 Drive
because
I didn't I no I did not I wouldn't know
I don't think so because I gave you one
no I didn't still don't have you have a
512 okay I'm still waiting for my one
terabyte No I gave you one what are you
talking about
no I definitely I'm pretty sure I gave
you I remember installing it it's still
awaiting because you were gonna give me
your old one and take the two terabytes
yeah I did that I've got the two
terabyte one oh this is a one terabyte
no but I bought a one terabyte one for
the nas
that's what's funny
the funny thing is your computer has a
512 gig M2 Drive
or a 500 gig M2 Drive
and the nas
has this one which is going to use like
30 gig of if not less
so this is slightly better in some ways
than your computer
how does that make you feel I hope this
is the right Drive
probably
underappreciated all right especially
with that whole like editing the bottom
of the video
yeah that was fun
oh I put the wrong screw in you know
that close-up you got of me yeah that
was the wrong screw that was the m dot
that was the M2 screw because it's it's
the same size but it's like flat so now
I'm going to have to transport that guy
here and put this guy
next time I'm buying a pre-builtness
yeah more of this story never listens
one yeah
well actually I've never told people to
listen to Linus but Linus has told
people to listen to me no so yeah he
apologized for being wrong and then he
was like go watch channel instead Mr
Sweeney probably knows things that we
don't but even based on what we can see
for ourselves if what Sony's saying is
true he wasn't Shilling for the PS5
don't take my word for it watch this
great take from the Cherno reacting to
Mark Sony's presentation so
it's one zero one one zero to me I
realistically ever made reference to
another YouTuber have I I think so well
you think I don't do that are you saying
that I'm not like you don't interact
with the community I'm not Community
yeah well I hate the community we all
right well know that based on my way
Sparky video
yeah I should probably do some more
collabs
if anyone's watching this and they want
to like hit me up to do a collab I'm
down don't quote me on them actually if
anyone wants to do a collab where they
just come here like right now and help
me get the screw out then that's a
that's a done deal this stupid screw man
screw you oh wait it's the wrong screw I
think it looks much too fat that was the
problem all right back to the table
this table is very famous because it's
got
a lot of stuff on it for example here it
here's the thing I was looking for wait
oh we had the blue tape on it I guess we
never took that off all right there you
go
that looks better look at that beautiful
beautiful that table always has the
answer all right back to the table
power supplies
I'm not looking forward to this power
supplies are like my least favorite part
to install because there's always like a
lot of cables
and they're always annoying let's just
bend these out of the way what the heck
is this nobody connected to anything has
anyone ever made like a a real time
CPU installation
or rather computer assembly video
because I feel like
I feel like the social media Industries
that's an unrealistic expectation but
how easy it is to assemble computers all
right this guy's in now
PSU screws eh what did they look like
back to the table I think
um
this looks a bit wrong no
no I know what I'm looking for
but does the table have the right answer
oh on the network the network card
I need that as well and then the actual
hard drive for the NASA's here oh
there's already one in there what the
heck why is that in there yeah you know
what I'm just gonna unscrew the two that
seem to already be screwed in and use
them because I don't think I need more
than two to hold this guy and it's not
like this NASA's gonna be all
in an earthquake I hope I remember that
earthquake that we had a while ago
that was that's like one earthquake
oh really yeah this is like an
earthquake every 10 years here and it's
usually mild but that one was pretty
that one was pretty pretty hefty yeah I
remember I think that was like I was in
bed at home I was also in bed
I was in bed at home delaying myself and
going to work or something this is
before the office oh yeah but like I was
still like I was not I didn't want to
get up and then I was like oh crap I
better get up
I just looked at the ceiling and I'm
like that falls how am I gonna Dodge it
I was like stage five lockdown just
earthquakes yeah
this is becoming a bit of a Tales from
the office all right that guy's in now
for the big fat one this one the plus
sized connector goes in luckily we have
no GPU which is nice oh yeah the network
card the 10 gigabit or whatever the only
reason I have to use this
um instead of just using the two and a
half gigabit uh
like motherboard Lan Port ethernet port
is because that one's not supported by
trunass which is the operating system
we're using and this one is and this one
I just had from my old
uh
like my old motherboard that I had for
my threadripper
1950x which actually in that computer so
we have this computer as well that's my
old computer
that is um
I believe are going to be our QA kind of
build machine for our continuous
integration
and that has a 1950x in it
and a 1080 TI which is probably a bit
overkill for
QA machine but
maybe I'll repossess that 1080 TI um all
right we're actually in a good place
right now I think is there any other
power we need surely not but there are
more connectors VGA this must have been
from when we were testing it using your
GPU so we don't need this oh and here's
the the SATA SATA
s-a-t-a
no I say s-a-t-a thank you
do you have the SATA yeah so that's
important and then the drive and then if
we connect this guy and we boot him up
and I'm hoping I have a SATA cable here
I'm not seeing one which is
disappointing the table doesn't have a
the table had everything though for
those of you who don't know why we keep
mentioning the table it's because ever
since this broke which as we established
in the start of the video was a very
long time ago
this table has contained just components
from this like we've showed the table to
him we've had this table here just with
com with like computer components like
that it's been there for months like
it's an unusable table in the office
so that's why we keep talking about it
because it whenever something's been
lost in the office or we've needed
something that table has come through
for us apart from like literally right
now because where is that Sata cable
this everything's useless without this
we're going to use this one I didn't
want to use it because it's got like
connectors so my function is a good kind
of external one to have but whatever
we'll use it for now and then I'll
replace it when I find another one so we
plug this bad boy in
to the drive I'm just going to boot this
up first and see if it works
before I install it a bit more
adequately than this
and then where's that power connector ah
the USB is not connected
oh no is that going to be really hard to
connect like it'll lose it damn when I
pulled this off the motherboard I pulled
it off with the
little guard look at this
I was looking at this being like why
does that look like that turns out
because when I pulled this off because
these USB 3 connectors are like always
so stiff
and hard like look at this all right I
think I might put it back on there all
right I said we screw the external USB 3
ports I don't think we need them power
is in for the drive
now we just need an actual power cable
and also we can yeah we can put it up
through this monitor
see if it works let's just take this
power in we go and that's it oh and the
network one where's the network
wasn't our ethernet cable
all right that's in how do we turn on
the power supply that's on
all right is everyone ready this is the
moment of the Moment of Truth wait
yeah there's no way I actually connected
the the uh front panel i o wait unless I
never disconnected it no but I'm pretty
sure I did
oh that's the worst part of any build is
connecting that stupid front panel i o
thing
oh it's already connected yes
oh that's such a win
good all right here's the power button
on this side
right
ready
make sure you capture all the smoke
it's on the CPU fan spinning
this is probably going to light up in a
second or not if it's broken I already
see it lighting up I think
it's probably just hitting a cable
wait
actually that's not hitting a cable what
does that sound wait that's the drive
okay it's on
that was a very delayed
boot thing new CPU installed
uh
I guess I'll reset it
okay the keyboard doesn't work it's
getting power at least
oh no
I knew those Father's Day flowers were a
bad idea
it's okay the
the that's safe
I'm gonna try a different USB port
control delete work no
why is this not working is that yeah
it's coming from this drive yeah well
the keyboard doesn't work
oh did something here this is the
longest boot ever well I don't like the
weird clicking that seems to be coming
from this hard drive I feel like that
shouldn't be happening and also this
looks like it's in some kind of weird
boot loop I don't know why maybe I
should go into the setup and see what's
up like listen to that what's going on
why why would it be doing that okay bios
has been reset food failure detected
sure uh load optimized defaults then
boots let's do that if you could go back
in time and have a conversation about
yourself with yourself about the nurse
what would you say ah nothing I I don't
know I don't think I I don't think this
is necessarily a bad setup I just think
that it's just not working for some
reason
which is a bit unfortunate I mean it's
possible that whatever M2 SSD I just
shoved in there is wrong oh look no it
worked
turn us
beautiful there's movement on the screen
what is this root Mount waiting for cam
I have very low hopes that this will
work like what the heck's going on it's
just it's the only thing that's making
this worse is the weird clicking
error 5 retry is exhausted soft reset
what is happening man maybe it's this
drive it's just like the drive's just
dead
and it's trying to do stuff I think that
might be the problem do you think that
that's maybe what killed the previous
CPU I don't know if a hard drive can
kill a CPU if so then we need to punish
this one bought it now everything's fine
but the drive failed and whipped it
go through this two-month process again
with the drive and the web interface
apparently could not be accessed this is
a complete disaster okay well here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to
probably shut this down and this sounds
like a printer you like that I'm going
to get rid of it I'm gonna disconnect
this drive and try and boot up again
okay goodbye Drive
okay well that was quick setting up
harvesting that seems to have worked
yeah there you go but it still says the
web interface could not be accessed
which is sus because I definitely
plugged it oh I plugged it into the what
a piece of garbage I am I plugged it
into the motherboard I should have
plugged it into this
oh there we go there we go so 192.168
2015. I don't know if it's
I feel like my admin password might be
different have you ever wrote them down
in my notes like a grandpa
ah yes I did
we're in
um
all right 12 threads add to zero percent
highest usage it's working hard
all right cool
yeah everything's good to go we just
need to put that main disc in
so but too bad it's like broken so let's
shut down this puppy so this is how it's
supposed to be I believe and then we'll
Chuck in the power and we'll probably
experience the clicking again everyone's
favorite clicking all right I reckon
it's gonna work
there's the clicking
I'll just make sure
guys why is my why is my hard drive
making that noise
I need an expert to tell me what the
problem is
I swear I haven't been abusing it it
says root Mount waiting for cam
that almost like sounds like it can't it
can't seek properly Tim have you been
taking out your anger on that drive yeah
I think that drive is just dead how did
this happen
why is the drive dead it's like an eight
terabyte drive I don't want to buy
another one of those all right well the
web interface is back yeah and see that
just that drive does not seem to be
working
well at least we I'm pretty sure we got
all the data off the drive I can't
believe this pile of garbage what if
it's a stupid Sata cable okay let's try
a different cable and we should probably
go to the BIOS and see what the BIOS
says about this drive I feel like it's
like just damaged internally or
something
but how
it's been sitting on that table for
months people are probably upset that
I'm not like I don't have like an
anti-static wristband or something I
don't want to actually use that that
wash counts as a matter I like to live
dangerously hence my disregard for
anti-static wristbands all right let's
just Chuck this back on
and I'm gonna go to the BIOS I think
take a trip to the BIOS yeah there's no
record of the drive in the Bios
I can't believe this all right let's
investigate further I'm gonna take this
apart
yeah close your eyes kids if we can look
back on this year and take one thing
away it's that we got the nest working
hopefully goals for this year get the
ass get the nurse work yeah the two
separate goals that's our epic and jira
what do you think we'll see in here like
a dead mouse or something else
I'd have to there's two more screws here
that are somewhat hidden so I'd have to
take that apart but I don't know that
that's definitely gonna like break the
warranty so maybe I'll just give this to
them and be like sorry guys this drive
just completely broke for no reason it
seems unless Tim has been doing things
to it that I'm not aware of so yeah what
started off as a fun video
has ended in tragedy yet again here at
Studio Channel
um we have a clicking hard drive and it
doesn't show up in the Bios it doesn't
show up in true Nas
but the CPU looks like the CPU works so
yeah I don't know if anyone has any
suggestions the suggestion probably just
gonna buy it buy an ass which is
probably what it should have done let's
be real but uh thanks to Linus we are
yet again stuck in
this situation where it could be months
and I was really hoping to have this
done by a lot of debt I mean I could
just buy another one of these because
odds are we're gonna expand anyway
so while this one's getting warranty
fixed or whatever on Earth I'm gonna do
with this guy mail it out to a lucky
subscriber
uh uh I might just pick up another one
of these except see this is what happens
I buy like a Seagate drive it fails and
I'm like okay I guess I'll buy a Western
Digital Drive
and they fail as well so
um Samsung a Samsung drive has never
failed on me but I've never had a
Samsung drive that isn't an SSD or an M2
I don't know if they make the screen
disc yeah
so I don't know spinny disks or maybe
I'm just stupid for having spinny discs
and I should just switch to ssds so an
eight Tera does an eight terabyte SSD
exist
yeah it does it's a it's a well here's
here's a how big is this one four
terabytes is 400 it's almost 500 bucks
so yeah
but anyway thank you guys for watching
the NASA update office devlog
I will uh see you guys next time goodbye